only on CBS this morning two men who say
that Michael Jackson sexually abused
them as children are now explaining why
they are coming forward Wade Robson and
James safe Chuck detailed the alleged
abuse and a new documentary premiering
on HBO this Sunday
Jackson has always denied any
inappropriate behavior with children we
spoke to his family this week and they
insisted this documentary is full of
lies Robson and safe to admit to lying
in the past but they told us they are
telling the truth now now you may find
some of this interview disturbing this
is the truth of what happened but the
reason for me to tell it now the reason
to do this film is so much bigger than
Michael it's so much bigger than me and
James in Jackson fans as you know or
adamantly defending him and saying that
you all are admitted liars
you're just opportunistic and trying to
get money from the estate and from
Michael Jackson what do you all say to
that it's an old argument that they've
used they say it's just about the money
for me the lawsuit was about fighting
back for little James nobody fought for
me as a kid but I'm old enough now to
fight for myself in the HBO documentary
leaving Neverland James safe Chuck and
Wade Robson claimed they were sexually
abused by Michael Jackson as young boys
both men say it was having children of
their own that helped them come to terms
with the alleged abuse if I never had a
son I might still be in silence really I
think there's a really good chance
mm-hmm I had become so disconnected from
myself as a little boy over the years in
through the process of kind of pushing
all of this down but I had no I had no
relationship with little weight I had no
kind of concept or care for in my mind
little my son did you see yourself as
when I started having visions or images
of what happened to me happening to my
son and I sand I saw images of Michael
doing it to my son and that was the
first time
that those kind of thoughts in relation
to Michael ever had an extremely
negative scary emotional reaction in me
you know it was once I could see really
understand this is what a little boy
looks like and feels like and thinks
like and behaves like this is what
innocence feels like that was me I think
your mothers are going to be in for some
criticism they are prominently featured
in this documentary just kid things they
were just doing kid things he just came
across as a loving caring kind song as I
watched that I had a lot of questions
about how the behavior of your mother's
killer yeah the parents are groomed the
parents are groomed the parents are
groomed as well Michael spends a lot of
time talking to your parents and
connecting with them and building
relationships he pays attention to them
and they're groomed over the time it is
their job to protect us and they didn't
but I try to look at it from their point
of view without letting them up though
because obviously that's their job what
about Michaels staff list a fur
everywhere Michael had so many people
employees running his life running his
career running his life secretaries
security guards to make sure that the
room I was in with him was secure and
closed off in private so he could do
anything he wanted with me she said
people had to know that this was going
on it's hard for me to believe this was
going on that people didn't know or at
least people had to wonder what is going
on something weird is going on here
where does Michael Jackson sit with you
both today I don't think I can answer
that
it's yeah I still have really I can't
yeah a lot of mixed feelings there's
still there's still a bit of love and
there's still it's almost like a guilt
for saying the truth like a the Traynham
my key betrayed yeah it's like I still
have those old wiring you know but still
there so you know my relationship or my
understanding my relationship with him I
think is gonna it needs a lot of work
the Jackson family points out to us that
your story's changed after Michael's
death is what they're saying that if he
were still alive you all would not be
sitting here talking to us right now
there would be no movie there would be
no documentary you would not be talking
what do you say to them right if Michael
was still alive and all of the other
rest of the details of my life were the
same meaning I became a father right and
I went through the same process that I
did of this realization and going
through the healing process my belief is
that we'd still be doing this of course
some details may be different James I
don't I don't know what I've taken this
to my grave I certainly planned on doing
that so I had no expectations of ever
telling anyone so you know if he if he
was still alive yeah yeah I don't know
maybe I would have taken it to my grave
I don't know it's interesting that James
talks about the guilt that he feels and
you can see he is still extremely
fragile he's married he has three
children Wade is married and has one son
and both of them said the the births of
their sons were a very defining moment
for them they've had therapy they've had
breakdowns it's been a very difficult
road for them we have to stress again
you know the first case with Michael
Jackson in 1993 he settled for 22
million dollars that was a jordan
chandler case and in the trial in 2005
he was acquitted so the Jackson family
is very adamant that you must mention
that he has never been found guilty of
any of these charges still what these
what these young men are saying is very
very serious and very very disturbing
they say it's our story and our story to
tell that both things are true in their
opinion Michael Jackson was a genius a
musical talent but he was also someone
who abused young boys yeah and that
story they tell when they talk about the
old wiring yes so complex it would seem
to be that if you were making up a story
you wouldn't have all that messy
complexity in it that's what makes them
seem so
on those details they have always been
consistent always leaving Neverland airs
Sunday March 3rd and March 4th on HBO
and on today's CBS s morning podcast
we're going to talk to the documentaries
producer and director Dan Reed he was
here on Tuesday and we continued our
conversation later that day you can
listen on any major podcast platform
we'll be right back to watching CBS this
morning